And an image from the files shows
Jeffrey Epstein and this guy looking at
what appears to resemble a sacred cloth
from Mecca in Saudi Arabia laid out on
the floor.
This is One Ummah Sadaqah Jariyah video.
If you care about the dunya more than
akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masajids that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
One Ummah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them. It's far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The
decision is yours. The link is there.
Donate now. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. So, when it
comes to the issue of the kiswah, uh,
there's new, uh, video, well, pictures
that came out where it is placed on the
floor by this sultan.
Uh, the sultan and Epstein are staring
at it with their hands in their pocket,
which you can see probably on the
screen. Here's a video of a man, I don't
know who he is for that matter, from a
YouTube channel explaining the details,
the ins and outs. So, this is very
interesting because the thing is here,
I'm in double-minds of is it something
that's intentional? Um, that's certain.
Number one, why is the kiswah on the
floor?
Uh, it could have been hung up. Um, we
can give
good assumptions, but you know, when
we're dealing with an individual like
Epstein,
yeah, but let's see, inshallah. So,
here's the video. Let's watch the video
inshallah for ourselves and find out
what's exactly going on. Who is the
sultan? And what's the connections to
Epstein? Is it just an innocent, um, uh,
meeting? Uh, I mean,
yes, you know, there were individuals
involved in this, um, thing, even
certain Arabs, etc., which we can see.
However, that doesn't mean necessarily
that they are using the kissul for
satanic things. Even though certain
things that they are doing is a little
bit satanic and obviously,
um, off the marks in in in many ways.
They're very satanic should we say. Um,
so yeah, let's watch this inshallah and
see what is the story behind this.
shopping or whatever in duty free. This
is the guy that owns it.
And an image from the files shows
Jeffrey Epstein and this guy looking at
what appears to resemble a sacred cloth
from Mecca in Saudi Arabia laid out on
the floor.
So, Epstein is pictured alongside the
Sultan
and both men have their hands in their
pockets at the bottom of a staircase and
are looking down at an object which
appears to be very similar to the
Kiswah, the black gold embroidered cloth
that covers the Kaaba.
Okay, so we can see clearly that there
is, um,
it's on the floor, but here there's a
picture of him and they're both eating
cookies and whatever it is for that
matter.
Uh, they they they they both look like
they just, uh,
woke up or something like that. So, I I
don't know. There's nothing that we can
say Islamically, uh, to accuse anyone.
Obviously, we know what Epstein is about
and him praising Tommy Robinson is a
friend, buddy and, you know, uh, these
pedophiles, they all look like this
middle middle-aged white men. Not I'm
saying not that I'm saying every single
one of them are like that. This is their
problem, okay? This is their their
disease and that's why every accusation
is a confession. They think we're like
them. We're not. So, let's see inshallah
what, uh, happens. So, here you can see
it looks quite personal with the picture
of them eating food. At the center of
Islam's holiest site in Saudi Arabia.
And the image was sent as an attachment
from a redacted email address to Epstein
and another redacted email address on
May 8th, 2014.
And in the body of the message, the
sender says, "Be careful what you think
is a giant wallet in someone's trouser."
In what appears to be a lewd joke. It's
not clear if the comment is related to
the picture with the cloth.
But, it was revealed from, you know,
emails in the Epstein files that pieces
of the sacred cloth were delivered to
him
through a number of intermediaries,
correspondence dated February-March 2017
shows that, hey, you know, Jeffrey wants
this, and you can see it is shipped by
air freight from Saudi Arabia to Florida
via British Airways. So, interesting.
So, we know that there was a
you know, UAE woman, a businesswoman,
who was involved in sending this. It
seems like she has connections to the
Sultan, this individual here, because
he's the one that's there. So, it was
sent by her. There might be some kind of
connection between the two, we don't
know. So, he is there, obviously,
looking at it. I don't know if he was
there at the Epstein
Island or whatever for that matter, and
he was like, you know, this was sent to
me by someone. Maybe there might be no
connection between the Sultan and the
UAE
Arab woman who sent this. And the
shipment arrived at Epstein's home in
March 2017.
But, it's not clear where the image of
Epstein and the Sultan in 2014 was
taken.
Because of the deep religious
significance, it would be
very disrespectful for the Kiswah to be
placed on the floor. But, you see how
they're not standing on it or anything
like that.
Now, the Sultan had a long-standing
relationship with Epstein. Years after
Yeah, that's very important to mention
that they are not stepping on it. They
are looking at it. Um, and, you know, if
they were trying to I mean, it's it's
very like there could be reason why it's
on the floor. They couldn't hang it up.
So, we can give that excuse in a sense
where it could have been hung up, but it
is not possible cuz it is quite big. If
you could see it, it is quite big. So,
again, though, to something that is that
precious to be put on the floor, as
Muslims, there is no I mean,
yeah, it's it's it's a bit bizarre. It's
a bit bizarre. It's it's it's it it is a
bit sinister. from the 2008 conviction.
And several emails between the two
discuss sexual experiences and talk
about women using degrading language.
In one email, after discussing religion,
cuz Epstein wanted to know if Muslims
could be friends with Christians and
Jewish people, and he said,
"Absolutely."
But, anyway, so, they're having this
religious discussion, and then the
Sultan says, "I got to get off right now
cuz I'm going to go sample a fresh 100%
female Russian at my yacht."
And then Epstein says, "100% Russian or
100% female?" He said, "100% female."
And Epstein says, "You better check."
And in another email, the Sultan says to
Epstein, "By the way, the Ukrainian and
the Moldavian arrived." So interesting
here, as you can see, this Sultan was
actually kind of giving him doubt. He
was asking, "Can you be Muslim with us?
Can you be friends with us?" Yes, you
can, but not intimate friends. Not I
mean not not close close friends. What
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala mentions that.
So he's giving him doubt, and then he's
saying, "Now I'm going to go see my
Russian
girlfriend."
Which is obviously we know it is haram,
and then they're like, "Oh, is he Is she
100% female?"
Which you can see what's going on here.
But at least from the Sultan's point of
view, there's no um
children and kids and minors involved in
this matter, so from what we can see.
Big disappointment. The Moldavian is not
as attractive as the picture, while the
Ukrainian is very beautiful.
And then Epstein said, "Well, you need
to make sure all the time that it's not
Photoshop." And the Sultan apparently
found her too skinny and too short.
In other emails showed Epstein sending
the Sultan a link to escort services in
Italy, to which the Sultan responds,
"Wow."
So I went to the Wayback Machine for the
day of the email because there was a
link to see if I recognized any of the
women from other contacts. None of them
looked familiar. Uh so I don't even know
which one they were referring to. It
just goes to a specific page.
And then separately, in another email
from the Sultan to Epstein, he makes a
joke about Muslim worshipers being
terrorists.
He said, "A friend of mine went to the
mosque in Saudi. He said, 'With all
these terrorists, frankly, you can't
tell whether the guy standing next to
you is just scratching his balls or
fiddling with the detonator.'"
Well, you can see um you know, I think
Islamophobia is of least concern when it
comes to
what this Epstein was doing. And yes, so
we need to be very careful, guys,
because there is no evidence in the
Sharia to say that he had extramarital
affairs. He's just making comments, and
comments don't necessarily mean
anything. Could be showing off the
Epstein etc. But one thing is clear that
he is talking about girlfriends and
women where Epstein is involved with
children and minors. Yes.
And the Sultan is one of the most
prominent business figures in the UAE.
He has been the chief executive of DP
World
since 2016
and the company's chair since 2007.
Now,
one of the interesting [clears throat]
things, he also pops up in this in a
Turkish thing. So, what's happened is
the Ankara Public Prosecutor's Office
launched an investigation
after an opposition party MP highlighted
a reference in Epstein's 2008 civil case
saying that he had transported minor
girls from Turkey, the Czech Republic,
Asia and numerous other countries, many
of whom spoke no English. Wow. Wow, even
in Turkey. Subhan Allah. They would even
do this
in Turkey. And there's hundreds of
thousands of Turkish girls that are
missing.
So now the prosecutor's office is, you
know, examining these 3 million
documents to see, "Hey, is there any
more about Turkey?"
And one of the things that they've said
is, "We propose the urgent establishment
of a parliamentary commission to
investigate whether there are any
Turkish children who are victims in the
Epstein case. And if so, their fate,
rehabilitation and protection if they're
alive and accessible."
And one set of emails
between Epstein and the Sultan,
it arranged for Epstein's personal
masseuse to work at the spa at in a in a
hotel in the city of Antalya so she
gains better experiences.
And Epstein says he wants the masseuse,
who he says has a Russian passport,
to learn as much as she can, all
treatments etc.
So the Sultan sent the request to the
billionaire founder of the hotel chain
who said he would make sure it happened.
And now those billionaire hotel owner
said, "I didn't know that Epstein was
involved. I didn't know."
But that his IT department was looking
into whether any of the women brought
there were minors.
Now, sticking with the UAE, the director
of the UAE's permanent committee for
human rights had repeated contact with
Epstein. So, emails released in the
Epstein files revealed repeated contact
between UAE diplomat Hind Al Owais and
Jeffrey Epstein between 2011 and 2012.
And the messages show this diplomat
arranging meetings for Epstein with
herself and her sister. And basically
saying, "Oh, you know, it takes longer
for two girls to get ready. I can't wait
to introduce you to my sister. She's
even prettier than me. How much time can
you spend with us?" Wow.
Uh wow, what could you say to that?
That's um
very very uh bizarre. And
uh
sometimes the Arab girls in certain
countries, whatever, they have this
inferiority complex. So, they they see
this white man as, you know,
you know, way above them. Uh so,
anyways, And Epstein's calendar messages
show in-person meetings repeated
coordination with her.
And she got this UN role after doing all
of these things for Epstein.
So, it just shows sometimes that people
are working their way up in different
ways, subhanallah.
Um
you know, it happens. So, obviously, we
have no evidence. Uh we have to be very
careful with this cuz this is
a Muslim woman. So, obviously, it's the
emails, etc. We don't know if it's
fabricated. We don't know. What I'm just
saying is
very very weird. Yes, as you can see,
subhanallah, what we can see from those
who are involved um Arabs from UAE, etc.
Uh there is
I So far, there's nothing to do with
it doesn't seem anything to do with um
in this per se minors, etc.
Uh which you have seen with the other
leaders, etc. Not that I'm saying they
may or may not be, but so far, you can
see, you know, the most we've heard is a
two Arab girls wanting to meet Epstein
and talking about one being prettier
than the other, spending time with them.
Um again, we have to be careful
islamically uh because we can't make any
accusations. And then you've got this
sultan who is
involved in the kiswah thing,
being there, etc. Subhanallah. But one
thing that we learn in all of this,
brothers and sisters, subhanallah, how
Allah subhana wa ta'ala exposes people.
And subhanallah, how Allah subhana wa
ta'ala, you know, and and believe me,
Allah would never expose anybody unless
they are hell-bent on misguidance. Allah
would never expose. It may remind me of
Omar ibn Khattab when he caught a thief.
And the thief said, "By Allah, it's the
first time I'm doing this." And he said,
"You are lying. For by Allah, if it was
the first time, Allah would never have
exposed you." Meaning you was
perpetually doing this. And these
sultans, we don't know how they're
involved, why they're involved, if
they're blackmailed. We don't know. But
you can see it was clearly a ring that
had those people in the high echelons,
billionaires, government
representatives, presidents involved in
this satanic satanic cult. And these two
individuals here, obviously, you can see
shady stuff going on.
Why is the kiswah on the floor? What
does it mean? Why was it sent to him?
There is nothing to indicate anything
satanic or ritual going on.
But is it possible they can that's in
Epstein's hands? Of course. I mean, he
most likely did. Now, did this Arab
sultan and this other woman that was
involved, did they send it intentionally
for him to do this? Was it a gesture
because he was known to be a
billionaire? They're working on the
sharia Bitcoin. We don't know. But what
we know is, guys, this is satanic. This
is satanic. And Allah subhana wa ta'ala
has told us in the Quran. That's why
sura baqarah was revealed. And
subhanallah, you should pray that in
your houses, brothers and sisters, and
protect you. The unseen world of
anything. These people high at the top,
if they are involved in these kind of
satanic things. Yeah, they have like a,
you know, a worship of the god Baal or
whatever it is. That means these people,
the ones right at the top who think
they're smarter than all of us all of
us,
if they are working right at the top and
they believe in this stuff, there is
truth to this. And forget them. Allah
tells us in the Quran. And that's why
Firaun, when you look at Pharaoh, he was
told by some kind of a magician or
soothsayer that a child from Bani Israel
is going to bring you end. How did they
know that information? Cuz Allah tells
us in the Quran, they go to the heavens,
certain heavens, and try to grasp some
information, and they are pelted by
stones. Subhanallah. and they grabbed
something something. So, you can see
Subhanallah there's truth to it.
Subhanallah from what they grab and with
Allah's permission cuz Allah has a plan.
They think they've got something, but
it's with Allah's plan. Subhanallah, and
no magic, no say, no evil eye, nothing
can harm a Muslim unless with the
permission of Allah Subhanallah and
that's why we urge you guys brothers and
sisters to do your morning and evening
of card by the Salah Pro app. And that's
all I have to bring to you guys. Very
satanic, very weird. As it develops the
stories, we will be bringing you more.
That's all I have to say inshallah. May
Allah Subhanallah protect us and sad to
see Muslim Arabs who have been falling
into this and Subhanallah hopefully
repent before it's too late sacrificing
the akira over a few moments of the
dunya.
That's all I have to say inshallah
brothers and sisters till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.